STEVE: PRESIDENT TRUMP BRAND
IN 2016 AS A CONSERVATIVE AND
THAT'S WHY HE WON ADD IT'S
BEST THAT IS WHAT WE ARGUE FOR
ON IS - - ON THIS SHOW FOR
POSITIVE POPULISM.
THE PRESIDENT TRUMP NEEDS TO
BE CAREFUL SOME DEMOCRATS ARE
TRYING TO STEAL HIS MESSAGE.
LOOK AT ELIZABETH WARREN.
IS EASY TO KNOCK HER ON HER
CLAIM OF NATIVE AMERICAN
ANCESTRY BUT TRUMP LITERALLY
DID THAT JUST MINUTES AGO BUT
IF YOU LISTEN CLOSELY SHE IS
BASICALLY RUNNING ON THE TRUMP
MIX ONE - - MESSAGE OF 2016 TO
MAKE GOVERNMENT DELIVER FOR
WORKING AMERICANS WITH THE
MIDDLE CLASS AND WORKING
FAMILIES AND NOW THAT IS HER
FOCUS.
>> THE MIDDLE CLASS IN THIS
COUNTRY HAS BEEN TREATED SO
UNFAIRLY.
WE WILL GO AFTER THE
MIDDLE-CLASS HOUSEHOLDS THAT
AMERICA.
>> AMERICA'S MIDDLE CLASS IS
GETTING HOLLOWED OUT.
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO WORKING
FAMILIES IN THIS COUNTRY?
WHY IS THE PATH GETTING
ROCKIER QUICK.
>> THIS IS WHAT WARREN SAID
ABOUT WASHINGTON'S CORRUPTION
LAST WEEK.
>> WE NEED TO CHANGE THE WORLD
IN WASHINGTON AND IT'S ABOUT
MONEY AND POLITICS AND THE
INFLUENCE OF MONEY I HAD THE
BIGGEST ANTICORRUPTION
PROPOSAL SINCE WATERGATE.
YES.
[APPLAUSE]
SO HOW ABOUT WE BLOCK THE
REVOLVING DOOR BETWEEN WALL
STREET AND WASHINGTON.
>> SHE NEEDS THROAT LOZENGES
TO BE HONEST SO TALK ABOUT
FIGHTING BIG MONEY AND
DRAINING THE SWAMP AND THE
REVOLVING DOOR.
>> ALL THAT MONEY GOES TO
HILLARY AND JEB AND SCOTT AND
MARCO AND ALL OF THEM THE
PEOPLE ARE LIKE PUPPETS WITH A
FIVE YEAR BAN ON LOBBYING BY
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND
CONGRESSIONAL OFFICIALS.
THEY WILL NOT BE TOO HAPPY.
A LIFETIME BAN FOR GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS LOBBYING FOR FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS.
.
>> THAT IS UNUSUAL FOR A
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE BUT THAT
IS WHAT TRUMP SAID LISTEN TO
HEALTH CARE.
>> WE WILL LOWER COLLEGE AND
SOLVE THE STUDENT LOAN
CRISIS.
>> I WILL TAKE CARE OF
EVERYBODY
EERYBODY
EVEYBODY
EVERYODY
EVERYBOY
EVERYBODY.
I DON'T CARE IF IT COST ME
VOTE SORRY NOT MUCH BETTER
THAN THEY ARE NOW.
>> TO TAKE CARE OF EVERYBODY?
THAT CANDIDATE SOUNDS SIMILAR
TO THIS ONE.
>> WE PRETTY MUCH BELIEVE
THREE QUARTERS OF US WANT TO
SEE RELIEF FROM STUDENT LOAN
DEBT AND AFFORDABLE HEALTH
CARE WE YOU CAN CUT PEOPLE OUT
WITH PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS.
.
>> I SUPPOSE IMITATION IS THE
GREATEST FORM OF FLATTERY FOR
THE NEED FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
SPENDING THE HIGHWAYS AND
TUNNELS THE BRIDGES ARE
FALLING DOWN.
HIGHWAYS ARE BAD MANY OF THEM
ARE DANGEROUS.
BUT WE WILL GET THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TAKING CARE OF
BUT WE HAVE TO DO IT.
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING WHERE IS
ALL THAT NEW MONEY PROMISED
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE TO HELP US
BUILD MASS TRANSIT TO HELP US
IN DEALING WITH TRAFFIC
CONDITIONS.
.
>> I WILL INSTRUCT THE
CURRENCY MANIPULATOR THE
GREATEST IN THE WORLD AND HE I
VALUE THEIR CURRENCY TO TAKE
UNFAIR ADVANTAGE OF THE UNITED
STATES AND ALL COMPANIES WHO
CANNOT COMPETE WILL FACE TARA
STAND TAXES AND TARIFFS.
>> THOSE THAT ARE UNDERCUT
RIGHT HERE IN AMERICA CHINA
HAS WEAPON EYES THEIR ECONOMY.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE SOMEBODY
WENT TO TRUMP UNIVERSITY.
THAT IS QUITE ENOUGH ELIZABETH
WARREN.
WE ARE NOT ENDORSING HER MANY
OF HER POLICIES WOULD BE
DISASTROUS FOR WORKING
AMERICANS IS ALSO TRUE MANY OF
TRUMP'S POLICIES - - POLICIES
HAVE BEEN DELIVERED INCLUDING
JOBS AND THE ECONOMY THE
POVERTY RATE IS AT ITS LOWEST
POINT IN A DECADE NOT BY
ACCIDENT BUT BECAUSE OF ACTUAL
POLICIES LIKE DEREGULATION AND
TAX CUTS.
IN THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT IN
HALF A CENTURY.
BY POLICIES THAT BOOST
BUSINESS CONFIDENCE TO
ENCOURAGE THE HIRING OF
AMERICAN WORKERS.
WITH A POPULIST PROMISE FOR
EXACTLY THE PEOPLE THEY
PRIORITIZE.
AND BOOMING AFTER SUFFERING
FOR YEARS WITH THE 400,000
MANUFACTURING JOBS COMPARED TO
A NET LOSS OF 200,000 UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
AND THE BEST PERFORMANCES 1997
BEFORE WERE CHINA JOINED THE
WTO THE ONLY ECONOMY DESPITE
THE ENDLESS CLAIMS OF THE
ELITIST ESTABLISHMENT THE
PRESIDENT DID FOLLOW THROUGH
BUT HE SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER BANNING ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS FROM WORKING WITH
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS AND A FIVE
YEAR BAN ON THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH AFTER THEY LEAVE
OFFICE.
SO TURNING THAT INTO THEIR
WINNING MESSAGE PRESIDENT
TRUMP NEEDS TO RECLAIM THE
MANTLE HERE IS HOW YOU CAN
RENEW YOUR POPULIST REVOLUTION
IN THE "STATE OF THE UNION"
ADDRESS.
ON JOBS TO GUARANTEE
RETRAINING FOR EVERY WORKER
THAT MEANS BOOSTING THE
AMERICAN WORKER TO HELP
PREPARE AMERICANS FOR THE NEED
OF THE BETTER WORKFORCE.
WITH OVER FOUR.3 MILLION
WORKERS BUT YOU CAN MAKE MUCH
MORE OF IT.
SO MAKE A PLEDGE BY 2030
AMERICA, NOT CHINA HAS A
TRANSPORTATION COMMUNICATION
AND TO REBUILD THE STRUGGLING
NEIGHBORHOODS WE HAVE
ALREADY'S ESTABLISHED THE
REVITALIZATION CANCEL AND
THOSE CAN BE THE VEHICLES AND
IN 2016 ON HEALTH CARE YOU
PROMISED TO TAKE CARE OF
EVERYONE THAN THOSE
IDEOLOGICAL NITWITS TRUST YOUR
INSTINCTS.
THAN THAT EVERY AMERICAN WILL
CHEER.
SO WHY THE HELL SHOULD THEY BE
ALLOWED?
AND WHY SHOULD THEY BE ALLOWED
TO DEAL WITH THEM?
AND THEN TO SHOW THESE
AMERICANS FIRST.
AND THEN TO STEAL THE WINNING
MESSAGE.
AND THEN THAT WILL SET THE
COUNTRY BACK THE MISTER